Speaker 1: Remember when the Republican Party
under Donald Trump completely abandoned, even
pretending to care about policy and instead
became all about cultural issues and so called
defending speech and being for speech, free
speech, more speech?
And also when they were against business regulations,
it was always complete and total nonsense.
But it is now actually come to a head with
former President Donald Trump actually cheering
Nigeria, banning Twitter and Facebook and
Trump suggesting more countries should do
it, and Trump alluding to the idea that he
should have done it as president of the United
States.
Whether he could have actually done that remains
an open question.
This is absolutely stunning because it not
only violates the principle of Republicans
being about more speech since these are speech
platforms.
After all, it also violates the principle
of Republicans being against business regulation
because it is outlaying if the U.S. were to
outlaw Twitter and Facebook a legal business
merely because Donald Trump doesn't like what
he perceives to be the political leanings
of their enforcement of terms of service,
Donald Trump put out a statement in which
he said, quote, Congratulations to the country
of Nigeria who just banned Twitter because
they banned their president.
More countries should ban Twitter and Facebook
for not allowing free and open speech.
All voices should be heard.
In the meantime, competitors will emerge and
take hold.
Who are they to dictate good and evil if they
themselves are evil, perhaps I should have
done it while I was president.
But Zuckerberg kept calling me and coming
to the White House for dinner, telling me
how great I was.
Twenty, twenty four? Trump asks.
So there there is a lot to say here.
But here is the most important point.
Nigeria banning those platforms has nothing
to do with Nigeria wanting Twitter and Facebook
to just allow more speech.
The way Donald Trump suggests Nigeria banned
those platforms to limit this free the free
speech of their citizens to complain about
the Nigerian government.
That's fundamentally what's at issue here.
So either Trump doesn't get it.
Or he gets it and he has the exact same goals,
but either way, it's absolutely despicable.
Now, as far as the right wing position on
this stuff.
Wasn't the perspective of Republicans about
this type of thing, that if enough people
are upset with Twitter and Facebook for, as
Trump calls it, not allowing free and open
speech, wouldn't people then abandon the platforms
and then wouldn't competitors arise?
And it will all be resolved by the free market,
as they love to say?
Of course, it turns out that, first of all,
most people are OK with the enforcement of
terms of service by these platforms.
People have not abandoned the platforms in
any significant capacity and the alternatives
have been terrible.
We've seen Parler Gabb I guess is a thing.
Mike Lyndell platform frank speech with.
I don't even know if that was online for more
than 30 minutes.
And then of course are the facts about the
platforms.
Look at Facebook, for example.
The top posts every day are almost all right
wing voices.
Conservatives are absolutely crushing it on
Facebook.
If you look, what were the top posts today
or this week?
It's Ben Shapiro, right winger.
It's Dan Bongino, right winger.
It's Sean Hannity, right winger.
It's The Daily Caller Post, Fox News Post.
And occasionally a Rachel Maddow post makes
it into the top Facebook posts of the day
or the week the conservative talking heads
dominate Facebook, and yet they claim to be
endless victims.
Now, one last thing on this.
When Trump mentions how Mark Zuckerberg was
coming to the White House and telling Trump
how great he is.
And that that's related to why Trump didn't
ban Facebook, although he should have.
Trump is admitting he didn't try to ban Facebook
at the time because Mark Zuckerberg was telling
him what a great guy he is and what a great
job he's doing.
So Trump is admitting something which we already
knew, which is Trump makes policy based on
who praises him and who criticizes him and
who is his friend and who likes him and who
does Trump like.
It's disgusting to hear Donald Trump admit
it, but we suspected that that was the case
all along.
We're going to have more on this story on
our Instagram.
If you are not following The David Pakman
Show on Instagram, follow us.
Follow, please follow at David Pakman show.
And if you want to see a really wild and wacky
piece of hate mail I got this morning, check
out my Instagram David Pakman.
We'll take a quick break